be zach godly i'm sure the nerves are
flowing he's done this before though
making a debut for a brand new team and
he's back in the big leagues here in
2021 with the brew crew
in the air left field a high towering
fly ball that's going to hang up
for billy mckinney that's a good way to
get it started one of your best hitters
in that number two spot that's where he
is as it gets out in front of an
off-speed pitch
high pop-up long run for bradley calls
everybody off and that'll be out number
two
bouncing ball to third shaw gobbles it
up one two three inning marlon's turn to
their ace this afternoon sandy alcantara
his sixth start of 2021
and sandy has his first strikeout
narvaez has been an offensive threat
this year for milwaukee
but sandy sets him down on three pitches
that one at 99 miles an hour a couple of
strikeouts in the first for sandy
three and two is outside and it's
another free pass issued to dickerson to
begin the second
and duvall lines the base it into left
field so the marlins have something
going here in the second godly brings it
home
and birdie grounds one to second wong
ureas
and virtually no chance of doubling up
the speedy birdie the marlins will have
runners on the corners with one out
last year
that roller will get the job done
dickerson scores
and it's a one nothing marlins lead
this is not a safe out call at first
base this has got to be an interference
call in some in some capacity
yep guiley's in the way and there is
contact they made contact at the foot
the left foot hit the foot of godly they
called interference sure did
and it gets away from narvaez again
and in the score is john bernie
watch how slowly this develops he's not
even looking bertie takes off for home
and he's going to be godly to the plate
anyway
3-2 pitch and down he goes and he is
over
was an all-star with the brewers in 18
as he lays off and will draw the walk
he walks garrett cooper and back-to-back
walks to start the fourth inning yes
he's been
in the alternative training site and
they've had games and at bats against
hitters but there's nothing like being
in the big leagues like this and he's
walked the first three batters
and the marlins have him loaded up
0-2 pitch and it's in there a cold
strike three
bagular the runner a third one-hour walk
cooper walked after him and dickerson
drew along
bases loaded two outs godly
trying to get out of a mess and he deals
a strike in there on a cold strike three
to end the yeti
marlon strand three in a game-changing
moment perhaps and now the brewers come
to bat with jackie bradley jr set to
lead off
as bradley jr rips one to right field a
base hit that's a good start first hit
of the game for milwaukee
swing and a miss
and
is down third strikeout for sandy
alcantara
oh look out godly gets a bunt down
impressively
aguilar makes the play
has to come hard and make a play that
became a do or die bunt right there if i
don't get the bat on the ball
it's gonna hit a finger it's gonna hit
me in the
clavicle wong can cash it in
he's been the brewer's hottest hitter
long in the air right field he's
watching
backflip goodbye
we're tied
that old man
fighting off 98 99 miles per hour on the
fastball
and was able to stay back long enough on
this breaking ball and gets sweet spot
to it
a no doubter
and a tie ball game for the brewers
payoff pitch
swinging a miss
held a couple of strikeouts in the
inning for alcantara but colton long
with the two run shot
three and one to diaz and he takes a
ball
that almost clipped him i think it did
yeah got him on the elbow
they hit batter
[Applause]
and the marlins with more traffic here
in this fourth inning
remember
godly on that punt
i thought it may have caught a piece of
his finger and now
credit council wants to go check
take him out of the game here that bun
attempt
off the finger and he just can't get a
grip
eric yardley out of the milwaukee
bullpen in left center making his 10th
appearance of the season nine innings of
work
and alcantara squaring early
maybe through it or not they're asking
he did not
and now that's really got the brewers
fired up boys
council is
a tick away from
sitting this one out in the clubhouse
and it may be coming right now
he's got the finger pointing and the
ejection and now
pat murphy is the one
who is thrown out
the ben you tell me is this
do you think he's pulling the bat back
right here no i i think he's just trying
to bun at it in a bad position that
works to his advantage on the ground
yardley's got it fire second base out
and wong on the transfer
lost the ball the out is recorded
an opportunity
an extra out here
so first and third now and two outs for
aguilar still a 2-2 game here in the
fourth
and now aguilar with a drive out to left
deep at the wall and gone
three-run homer for jesus aguilar
what a road trip
five in six days and the marlins jump
back in front
i mean the first ball that we've seen
hit between the white lines an entire
trip through the lineup
leads the yard to left and just enough
as it hits the top of the wall and goes
over sierra leads off
and gets a base hit through the left
side
wallace a strikeout and a hit by pitch
this afternoon sierra and diaz the
runners
second and first respectively that's the
base hitting to right field
sierra coming around third here's the
throw from right a little off the mark
and sierra scores
so wallach has himself an rbi single and
the marlins stretch it to his 6-2 lead
over back goes the other way that'll be
extra bases
long run for brenson
and big dan vogelback
with a one-out double
first step get alcantara
into the stretch they've done that now
try to get into that miami bullpen and
you're at the right part of the order
hit hard center field that is down base
hit
vogel back to third
omar narvaez with a single
travis shaw lines it to left stays up
for brinson vogelback gonna come home
here's the throw from lewis and they got
him
wallick backed up to get a good hop able
to recover and tag vogel back
now nice job by sweet lou comes in makes
a nice running catch gathers himself a
tough hop on wallach to your point did a
great job of backing up oh yeah this is
game number 13 for floral
minuscule 169 era
what's too bad about manny pina
fractured his toe hot shot through for a
base hit
luisa
with a multi-hit game
he's two out of three there's a good
start to this eighth inning
chopped to third fair ball bertie makes
the throw and gets the out
great play by birdie at third nice
stretch by aguilar
reyes picking him up and putting him
down down the line and that's out number
one full count pitch coming and called
strike three flouro got the corner
and that'll get us to the
ninth inning
and perdomo loses
that's
birdie
second walk for him
they picked off birdie who never stopped
running to second
the marlins are going to take a look at
this this might be a telling angle right
here
very close
yeah
birdie's in disbelief so i have to
imagine he never felt the tag
wow
sends one deep to center field it's off
the base of the wall
and casting hero wasting no time that's
a pinch hit double
with one out here in the ninth he comes
in the air to right center field duvall
coming in but sierra makes the play
it's a marlins win 6-2 the final